Les parents peuvent apprendre beaucoup de ça.
Mais pour moi, toujours s'adapter veut aussi dire quelque chose de plus profond.
Il faut que les parents s'échappent de cette camisole de force
qui veut que les seules idées que l'on puisse essayer à la maison
soient celles qui viennent des psychologues ou des gourous de l'épanouissement personnel,
ou des autres experts de la famille.
La vérité, c'est que leurs idées sont éculées,
alors que dans tous ces autres mondes, il y a de nouvelles idées
pour que le travail de groupe et d'équipe fonctionne bien.
Prenons quelques exemples.
Prenons le plus grand défi de tous : le dîner en famille.
Tout le monde sait qu'avoir un dîner de famille
avec ses enfants est une bonne chose pour eux.
Mais, pour beaucoup d'entre nous, ça ne marche pas dans nos vies.
J'ai rencontré un chef très connu à la Nouvelle Orléans qui a dit :
« Pas de problème, je vais décaler l'heure du dîner en famille.
Je ne suis pas à la maison, je ne peux pas être là pour le dîner de famille ?
On aura un petit-déjeuner en famille. On va tous se rencontrer pour un snack à l'heure de dormir.
On rendra les repas du dimanche plus importants. »
Et la vérité, c'est que des études récentes disent la même chose.
Il s'avère qu'il n'y a que 10 minutes de temps productif
dans un repas en famille.
Le reste est pris par les « ne mets pas les coudes sur la table » et «passe le ketchup ».
Vous pouvez prendre ces 10 minutes et les déplacer
à n'importe quel moment de la journée et obtenir le même résultat.
Donc décalage du dîner en famille : c'est ça, l'adaptabilité.
Une psychologue environnementale m'a dit,
« Si tu est assis sur une chaise dure, sur une surface rigide,
tu seras plus rigide.
Si tu es assis sur une chaise rembourrée, tu seras plus ouvert. »
Elle m'a dit, « Quand vous grondez vos enfants,
asseyez-vous dans une chaise droite avec un surface rembourrée.
La conversation ira mieux. »
Ma femme et moi, on a changé notre siège pour les conversations difficiles
parce que j'étais assis plus haut, dans la position de puissance.
Donc, changez de siège. C'est ça l'adaptabilité.
Ce qu'il y a, c'est qu'on trouve toutes ces nouvelles idées là-dehors.
Il faut les faire connaître aux parents.
Donc directive numéro un : toujours s'adapter.
Soyez flexibles, soyez ouverts d'esprit, laissez les meilleures idées gagner.
Directive numéro deux : responsabilisez vos enfants.
Notre instinct de parents est de donner des ordres à nos enfants.
C'est plus facile et, honnêtement, nous avons généralement raison.
Il y a une raison pour que peu de systèmes aient été
plus hiérarchisés que la famille.
Mais la leçon la plus grande que nous ayons apprise
est qu'il faut renverser la hiérarchie autant que possible.
Enrôlez les enfants dans leur propre éducation.
Hier, nous avions notre réunion en famille,
et nous avions décidé de faire des efforts sur les réactions exagérées.
Donc, nous avons dit : « D'accord, donnez-nous une récompense et donnez-nous une punition. Ok ? »
Et une de mes filles a dit, on a droit à cinq minutes de réactions exagérées par semaine.
On a tous aimé ça.
Mais ensuite, sa sœur a commencé à améliorer le système.
Elle a dit : « Ai-je droit à une réaction exagérée de cinq minutes
ou puis-je avoir 10 réactions exagérées de 30 secondes ? »
J'ai adoré ça. Utiliser son temps comme on veut.
Maintenant donnez-nous une punition ! Okay.
Si on arrive à 15 minutes de réactions exagérées, c'est la limite.
Chaque minute au-dessus de ça, on doit faire une pompe.
Alors vous voyez, ça marche ! Ce système n'est pas laxiste.
On y trouve beaucoup d'autorité parentale.
Mais on leur donne l'occasion de devenir indépendantes,
ce qui, bien entendu, est notre but ultime.
Juste au moment où j'allais partir pour venir ici, ce soir,
une de mes filles s'est mise à hurler.
L'autre a dit : « Réaction exagérée! Réaction exagérée ! »
et elle s'est mise à compter. Et dans les 10 secondes, c'était terminé !
Pour moi, c'est un miracle estampillé « Agile » !
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
Au fait, la recherche me donne raison là aussi.
Les enfants qui peuvent planifier leurs propres objectifs, définir leurs horaires hebdomadaires,
et évaluer leur propre travail, bâtissent leur cortex frontal
et prennent plus de pouvoir sur leurs propres vies.
Ce que je veux dire, c'est que nous devons laisser nos enfants réussir à leur façon
et oui, parfois, échouer à leur façon.
Je parlais au banquier de Warren Buffet
et il me grondait parce que je ne laisse pas mes enfants
se tromper avec leur argent de poche.
Et j'ai dit, « Mais si elles terminent dans le fossé ? »
Il m'a répondu, « Il vaut mieux terminer dans le fossé
avec 6 $ d'argent de poche qu'avec 60000 dollars de salaire annuel
ou 6 millions de dollars d'héritage. »
Donc, le fond du problème c'est de rendre vos enfants plus forts.
Directive numéro 3 : Racontez votre histoire !
L'adaptabilité c'est très bien, mais nous avons besoin de fondations solides.
Jim Collins, l'auteur de « Good to Great »,
m'a dit que les organisations humaines couronnées de succès, quelles qu'elles soient,
ont deux choses en commun :
elles maintiennent les acquis, elles stimulent le progrès.
Donc « Agile », c'est génial pour stimuler le progrès,
mais on me dit régulièrement qu'il faut maintenir les acquis.
Donc, comment fait-on ?
Collins nous a appris à faire une chose
qui se fait dans les affaires, c'est à dire définir sa mission
et identifier ses valeurs essentielles.
Donc, il nous a accompagnés dans le processus d'élaboration d'une charte familiale.
Nous avons fait l'équivalent familial d'une journée au vert.
Nous avons fait une soirée pyjama.
J'ai fait du popcorn. A vrai dire, je l'ai brûlé, donc j'en ai fait deux fois.
Ma femme a acheté un tableau de conférence.
Et nous avons eu une grande conversation, comme « Qu'est-ce qui est important pour nous ?
Quelles sont les valeurs qui comptent pour nous ? »
Et finalement, nous avons 10 déclarations.
« Nous sommes des voyageurs, pas des touristes. »
« Nous n'aimons pas les problèmes, nous aimons les solutions. »
A nouveau, la recherche montre que les parents devraient passer moins de temps
à s'inquiéter de ce qu'ils font faux
et plus de temps à se concentrer sur ce qu'ils font juste,
moins s'inquiéter des jours mauvais et préparer les bonnes journées.
Cette charte familiale est un moyen génial d'identifier
ce que vous faites bien.
Quelques semaines plus tard, l'école nous a appelés.
Une de nos filles avait eu une prise de bec.
Et soudainement, nous étions inquiets : étions-nous les parents d'une méchante fille ?
Et nous ne savions pas vraiment quoi faire,
donc, nous l'avons faite venir dans mon bureau.
La charte familiale était contre le mur,
et ma femme a demandé, « Ça entre dans une de ces catégories ? »
Et elle a passé la liste en revue et elle a dit,
« Rapprocher les gens ? »
Et tout à coup, nous avions une entrée en matière.
Une autre bonne façon de dire votre histoire
c'est d'expliquer à vos enfants d'où ils viennent.
Des chercheurs, à Emory, ont fait passer à des enfants
un simple test de « Que savez-vous ? »
« Savez-vous où vos grands-parents sont nés ? »
« Savez-vous où vos parents sont allés au lycée ? »
« Connaissez-vous quelqu'un dans votre famille
qui a connu une situation difficile, une maladie, et qui l'a surmontée ? »
Les enfants qui ont eu les meilleurs scores à ce questionnaire
avaient la meilleure estime de soi et un plus grand sentiment de pouvoir contrôler leurs vies.
Le test « Savez-vous » a été le meilleur indice
de la santé émotionnelle des enfants et de leur bonheur.
L'auteur de l'étude m'a confié que
les enfants qui ont le sentiment de faire partie d'une histoire plus grande
ont plus de confiance en eux.
Donc, ma dernière directive c'est : racontez votre histoire.
Prenez du temps pour raconter encore l'histoire des bons moments de votre famille
et comment vous avez surmonté les moments négatifs.
Si vous racontez cette histoire de bonheur à vos enfants,
vous leur donnez des outils pour les rendre plus heureux.
J'étais adolescent quand j'ai lu « Anna Karénine » pour la première fois,
et sa célèbre première phrase :
« Toutes les familles heureuses se ressemblent ;
chaque famille malheureuse est malheureuse à sa manière. »
La première fois que je l'ai lue, j'ai pensé « Cette phrase est idiote ».
Evidemment que toutes les familles heureuses ne se ressemblent pas !
Mais quand j'ai commencé à travailler sur ce projet,
j'ai commencé à changer d'avis.
Un savoir récent nous a permis, pour la première fois,
d'identifier les blocs de construction
utilisés par les familles heureuses.
Ici, aujourd'hui, je n'en ai mentionné que trois :
s'adapter tout le temps, responsabiliser les enfants, raconter son histoire.
Est-il possible, après toutes ces années, de dire que Tolstoï avait raison ?
Je crois que la réponse est oui.
Lorsque Léon Tolstoï avait cinq ans,
son frère Nicolas est venu vers lui
et lui a dit qu'il avait gravé le secret du bonheur universel
sur un petit bâton vert qu'il avait caché
dans un ravin dans le domaine familial en Russie.
Si le bâton était trouvé un jour, l'humanité entière serait heureuse.
TolstoÏ devint obsédé par ce bâton, mais il ne le trouva jamais.
Il demanda même qu'on l'enterrât dans ce ravin où il pensait que le bâton était caché.
Il y repose encore aujourd'hui, recouvert d'une couche d'herbe verte.
Pour moi, cette histoire résume
la leçon finale apprise :
le bonheur n'est pas quelque chose que nous trouvons,
c'est quelque chose que nous construisons.
Presque tous ceux qui se sont penchés sur des organisations fonctionnant bien
sont arrivés à peu près au même résultat.
La grandeur n'est pas une question de circonstances.
C'est une question de choix.
On n'a pas besoin d'un grand plan. On n'a pas besoin d'une cascade.
On a juste besoin de faire de petits pas,
d'accumuler de petites victoires,
de continuer à chercher ce petit bâton vert.
Au bout du compte, c'est peut-être la plus grande leçon de toutes.
Quel est le secret d'une famille heureuse ? Essayer !
(Applaudisements)